Now that we have all of the data set up and our pickup disappears, we need to now make
sure that we can display that data to our user using Unreal Motion Graphics.
So the first thing that we're going to be doing is we are going to be creating a user
widget.
So we're going to go to our user interface, we're going to select widget blueprint, and
then we're going to select the user widget, which will allow us to create a widget blueprint
that we can view on our UI.
So inside of our editor, we're going to hit control space to bring up our content browser,
and then I'm just going to do this in my content folder where my pickup and my blueprint interface
are currently located and just right click, we're going to go to user interface and widget
blueprint.
From our pick parent class, we're going to select user widget, and we're going to call
this user widget underscore UI, and then I'm going to double click on it to open it up.
I might open up offscreen, so let me bring that over here.
And with our HUD, the first thing we're going to add to it is a canvas panel.
Now a canvas panel allows us to have multiple HUD elements.
If we don't put a canvas panel on there, whatever element we apply is going to take
up the entire widget.
So if we were to put just a button, it would be just a button.
So let's pop over to the editor now, and we're going to look for our canvas panel.
There we go.
We're just going to drag and drop that right onto our UI like so.
So now we have the ability to add multiple things to this UI.
So what we're going to be doing is we're going to be adding a score and a text, sorry, a score
and a time using text.
So this is what we want to add.
We want to add these two things, and we're going to add some parameters to them as well.
So first off, we're going to come up here to text, and we're going to add that.
And we're going to call this first one.
We're going to set some things up here.
So let's call this score.
And we're just going to do zero, zero right now just to give us an idea of the size and
everything like that.
So let's go to our font here.
We're going to set this to 64.
And I probably should start from the top, but I wanted to get that size there because
I want this size to content enabled.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to take our position here and we're going
to move this just down a little bit like so.
So we'll make these numbers a whole and then we're going to move it over.
We'll say something like maybe like 100.
There we go.
The other thing we're going to do to this is we're going to put an outline on it of
say two.
This is just going to make it easier to read.
So we have our score and then we're going to go right click on that and we're going
to say duplicate and it's going to bring it right up there.
So right off the bat, we're going to call this one time.
There we go.
And the other thing we're going to do with this is we're going to come here to the anchor
and the anchor defines where this element is anchored on the UI.
And this is really important.
We'll see in a second here why this is so important.
So if you hold down control and you click over here on the far right hand side one,
it's going to move that time over there.
And the reason this is so important is if I was to drag on this handle here, notice
that the score and the time stay in the same location relative to the UI size.
So this is great because this means that I can make this UI for one setup and then have
it work on a bunch of different resolutions.
And I can ensure that that information stays exactly where I want it.
So for our time though, it is outside.
So we do need to come here to our position and we're going to move this over just a little
bit, maybe something like that will do negative like 390 maybe.
And then we're going to do the position here.
We'll just move this down a little bit.
I believe this one was at 70.
So we'll do this one at 70 as well.
There we go.
All right.
So we should have our time and our score.
And the next thing that we're going to do, so we should have something like this, we're
going to create a binding.
Now before I make this binding, there's something I want to mention about binding.
So these are incredibly easy ways to send data to and from your UMG UI elements.
But as your project grows in complexity, the more you use bindings, there is a point where
you're going to start to encounter a performance issue.
There's other ways to get and send data that are a little bit more efficient, but they're
outside of the scope of this tutorial.
So I just want to point out that while this is a very easy and quick and semi efficient
way to interact with text with UMG and data, as your project becomes more heavy, you could
encounter an issue in performance by doing this if you have like hundreds of UMG widgets.
So just keep this in mind.
This is simple and easy, but it does have the drawback that it could introduce some performance
issues as your project grows in complexity.
So what we're going to do is we're going to come over to our score and then under our
content and text, we have this create binding.
So we are going to create a binding that's going to bring us up a little editor here.
And inside of that editor, what we're going to be doing is we're going to do this.
We're going to get to the player pond.
We're going to cast to our sports car because that's where our current score is.
And then we're going to format that text so that we have the score and then the value
here, which we will automatically update from the value of our current score in our car.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So what we're going to do is we're going to right click and we're going to look for
get player pond.
There we go.
And then from our player pond, we're going to cast to BP and we want our BP, P sports
car.
Now we are going to turn this into a pure cast because we know what we are looking for.
So we don't necessarily need to put in any type of error correction or something if this
fails because we know that that value is going to be there.
So we're going to pull off of this and look for our current score.
And we are going to get the current score.
And then we need to look for another node here just called format.
And we want this text format text.
And what we're going to do here is go score and then value and make sure that you use
the curly brackets.
And that's going to give you this value right here input.
So we can take that and bring this in like so.
So what's going to happen once we get our UI set up for the other thing is when we just
compile this and we're going to go back to our designer.
So basically when we start the game, when we get some amount of scoring some points, this
is going to update right here.
So we'll see 10 or 50 or whatever the value happens to be.
And for our time, we're going to do something very similar.
We're going to create a binding.
We're going to cast to our game mode this time as our BP game mode, we're going to get
the time remaining.
And then we are going to put that into a format text just like we did with the score.
So let's go over here back to our blueprints.
So we're going to go to time and then here create a binding.
There we go.
And then we're going to get game mode.
And then from our game mode, we are going to cast to BP underscore GM vehicle basic.
There we go.
And we are going to right click and convert to pure cast.
And then we're going to pull off of this and we're going to look for the get time remaining.
All right.
And then we also want to format text.
And inside of our format text, we want timer and then double brackets value.
And then we're going to take our time remaining and bring that into our value right here and
then our result into the return value.
All right.
And let's just straighten that.
So that's what we have right there.
Let's compile and save.
Okay.
And then what we're going to do next is we're going to go over to our event begin play and
we are going to create this user widget and then add it to the viewport.
And remember that our what we're going to be accessing.
So I'm just going to close off my which is going to come here and we're going to go to
our blueprint and we're going to go to our BP GM vehicle basic.
Right.
And we're going to go off of this event begin play right here because that's we're going
to basically load our UI and then start our game.
So we're going to pull off of this and we're going to look for create.
W ID, there we go.
Create widget and then the widget that we want to create is our user widget UI.
And then we want to add to view the either we go add to viewport.
And what do we want to add to viewport?
Well, we want to add this right here.
All right.
So let's compile and save that.
And next up, we're going to talk about some testing and then creating further user widgets.